well as the migrant crisis at our
southern border rages on the white house
pledges to crack down on human
trafficking but critics say the
administration's policies are actually
fueling the uptick in trafficking former
acting ice director tom homan says
quoting the biden administration can't
take human trafficking seriously while
they have an open border because an open
border just invites more trafficking
because the chance of getting arrested
and caught are a lot lower when the
border patrol is busy with family units
at the border let's bring in texas
democratic congressman henry cuellar
vice chair of the house appropriations
subcommittee on homeland security
congressman thank you for joining us the
administration as we said they have
pledged to crack down on trafficking the
numbers tell a different story i want to
put these trafficking numbers on the
screen if we can showing that uh they've
increased from 947 to uh 1111 up 17
percent and the arrests have gone up
dramatically up 35 percent and the
critics who say you cannot crack down on
something that you are simultaneously
incentivizing what would you say sir
well i certainly say that the numbers
have
continued to increase i was looking at
the
numbers from the valley in south texas
and uh just this year october first this
fiscal year october first till now
there's been about a hundred and forty
thousand encounters that border patrol
has sent there now it's interesting the
numbers of uh unaccompanied kids uh were
about four percent family units were 23
and about 72 73 percent were single
adults so we're seeing an increase of
single adults which is a um
something that in the valleys where we
see most of the unincompetent kids and
family units so again you got to make
sure you catch them uh and and again use
title 42
title 8 and return people because again
if you don't return people the message
is that the border is open and people
are going to continue coming so you have
to make sure
that you deport them now i'll say this
the bind administration is still using
title 42 but they need to publicize that
if you notice there's not too many
pictures or images of people being
returned even though they are returning
thousands of people under that title
yeah you said this to the new york times
um
about the vice president kamala harris
you apparently tried to contact her you
said quoting here i say this very
respectfully to her i moved on she was
tasked with that job it doesn't look
like she's very interested in this so we
are going to move on to other folks that
work on this issue how is it possible
that the border czar is ignoring a
democratic congressman whose district is
along the border sir
uh you have to ask her that question uh
what i said uh was i'm gonna work with
the people the career people in homeland
security the appointees uh that are
interested in working on securing the
border you know a lot of us they don't
have to listen to me but they should
listen to the people that live on the
border they need to listen to ranchers
uh mayors county judges sheriffs police
folks that are on the border that see
this every day
and if they listen to people on the
border i think they will get a very
different perspective being 1500 1200
miles away is very different
from living on the border where we drink
the water we breathe the air we live
here we have our families here and
people
down here are very respectful of
immigrants they want to see them treated
with dignity and respect but at the same
time they want to enforce the law and
the law says that if you get to stay
here you stay and if you don't then you
will be deported
i have very little time sir but i'm
wondering if the vice president were to
call you back what would you say to her
very quickly
well you know certainly i i would engage
her and i want to give her my years of
experience i mean i've served on
homeland uh the oversight for uh over
eight years i sit in an appropriations
uh homeland for so many years also six
years so i've been somebody with
experience and i certainly want to give
her my perspective and i want to be
helpful to the vice president i want to
be helpful to the vice person but like
any other conversation you got to have
two people to have a conversation
someone's got to call you back
congressman cuellar thank you for coming
on
thank you so much hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now